when i was younger we played the squid
game if you cross the head of the squid
then you can walk on two feet we call
this the secret inspector yo son were
you off gambling again or what's good
i'm trying to think of other moments you
really not know the pin your grandmother
has straight up disowned you i do know
the pin
no please i'll definitely have the money
for you next week i'm good for it yo
next time i catch you and you don't have
my money i'm gonna take your lung out
sign here
i don't have a pen you have natural ink
right here
nose bleed
ow my nose it's bleeding contestants
today we're playing red light green
light oh snap i fudge and love this game
this was my [ __ ] when i was younger what
the hell everyone is getting shot
quick get to the exit what the heck is
this game dude you just need to hide
behind someone that way you won't be
seen i felt like if something was wrong
too but i was like it must just be
like it must be that good of a show
where people are just watching it
despite the horrible voice acting
the art student i used to play the squid
game
this is the way we would play the best
squid game meme i saw out of all of them
was the one where they took the graham
cracker and they copped in like a
diagram of a vagina and then
[Laughter]
that's good that's good those licks were
aggressive in that scene oh yeah that
[ __ ] was horny
first let me say
you know i just got to be that guy for a
second what it was awful though
yeah literally the worst tv show i've
ever seen
and i 100 mean that it's the worst tv
show i've ever seen yeah you guys all
liked it well it's actually quite bad
yeah and you're wrong yeah all 90
million of you that like that show
you're wrong
you have bad opinions about media and
you're the little [ __ ] [ __ ]
i can i can hear someone like
gripping through their steering wheel
like break it in half well it's because
you wash it with the english dubbing
like a few weeks before it like really
popped off it it showed up on my home
page on netflix and i was like
this looks interesting and then i played
the trailer and i told lena like we
should watch this she goes
nah it's just seems like a random ass
show
and then it blows up a couple weeks
later as we're watching it she was like
okay
maybe i should have listened yeah oh so
you knew it before it was cool that's
what you're saying right now
i can't really say that because you guys
all love squid games but i knew about
that [ __ ] two weeks ago yeah had i
pressed play i would have been ahead of
you all
and i also would have smoked weed while
watching it too so very cool
very cool i would have made that vagina
meme
honestly if i just had a little more
lead time
i would have made all the squid game
memes yeah like i would have been
prepared yeah so plus the chest sucks
anyways yeah is it not just kind of like
hunger games
it's not the exact same
sort of but i think right i was thinking
oh yeah i think i've seen this before no
i mean that premise i mean isn't that
like battle royale as well like isn't it
a bunch of kids killing each other for
money
it is but so is that
yeah multiple parts of that where
they're like oh just all right go for it
i think what makes this one right lights
are out
we're not watching
okay time to kill the other contestants
no no what i liked about that knife
about that was like
it wasn't like we're not watching it was
like we're watching yeah go for it yeah
just i just like that they kind of like
they're like oh the lights are off yeah
you know what i'm saying
it wasn't like all right contestants
and they like they they slipped it in
subtly you know when the guy died and
then all of a sudden like the
money drops down and they're all like oh
oh
it's like that yeah
you know what are you guys gonna do
really solid is
if they turn the lights off and i was
like oh then they turn them back on like
it was like too preemptive and then
those big ass doors like opened yeah
it's just one of those triangle dudes
and he walks down the ramp with like a
small satchel and just throws it in the
middle of the room and it
falls open there's like 20 knives roll
out and then he just turns around and
then just walks back
crowbars yeah
no 20 doll knives like butter knife oh
jesus
i feel what made
this version of you know everyone kill
each other for money hold on asteroids
oh jeez jesus christ yeah
well those came close what made this
version of the premise so relatable
though is
look like
everyone relates to debt you know yeah
like that is a universally understood
thing so i think that's what got people
invested because
i think that's the most depressing part
of the show is
you're sitting there watching it you're
like thinking about like your [ __ ]
credit card you're like oh damn would i
kill someone to pay off this credit card
like maybe yeah
i could
would i rob an old man
like of dementia of marbles to pay off
my credit yeah
yeah the
i think people
i saw people saying how
the second half sucks or whatever and it
definitely got slower i think it did a
good job it's it's a tough
thing to get out of i feel like in a
series where you have all that crazy
violence and all that tension and it's
like where does it go from here yeah
i thought it was good i thought like the
some of the plot lines were really
predictable though yes like the brother
yeah you know yeah and the and the old
man like
the moment he popped in i'm like this
fool made the whole thing yep yeah yeah
kind of some classic tropes in there but
you like to see those play out almost i
don't know like
the old guy was like so
i don't know um charismatic and
yeah that as an actor that dude nailed
it yeah amazing and so was the lead guy
i mean like yeah in the first episode i
was like this guy sucks probably because
of the voice acting but like as it goes
on the actual listening like
grandma i am bro
yes wait horse69 it's winning okay what
i didn't like was that the first episode
was so
engaging like when they actually get to
the game yeah and you're like holy [ __ ]
like that's one of the craziest moments
in the show yeah is when that first
shots fired
and you're like oh it's like that
holy [ __ ] because like up to there it
wasn't that like eerie or creepy or
anything you're kind of just like what
is this little organization yeah
underground
you know fight club for children's games
yeah and then the first guy you know
spoiler alert so when the first guy gets
fingered
[Laughter]
spoiler when the first guy gets
picked
you're like holy [ __ ] yeah and you're
super engaged and the rest of that game
is like the craziest tv i've ever
watched oh
it literally looked like a genocide
right crazy and then the second episode
you're like what's the next game what's
the next thing going to be and then they
all leave and the whole second episode
is you learning about their backstories
it's like i almost stopped watching it
because i was like this shit's boring as
hell like just coming off of the first
episode yeah i want to see some death i
i was i was willing to play ball with
that because i wanted to i wanted to
feel it you know i wanted to
care about who died that crazy woman
yeah she was insane drove a lot of the
story yeah she was the worst voice
acting by far oh i can't even imagine
what the english was horrendous
oh and it's so funny like the voice
actors like them using damn and hell all
the time
like they'd kill like they'd confront
someone and be like you're a damn idiot
yeah like there's no way that they said
that in korean the producers at netflix
they got the quote they got the quote
for the accurate
translation
you know yeah they're like whoa whoa
we have to pay more than a hundred bucks
yeah now we'll just yeah
get an intern have them do google
translate or anything and we'll just get
some people around the office and we'll
knock this out why did they get a young
guy trying to be an old guy yeah i don't
know just get an old guy yeah i know
that is literally
such a crucial part of watching an old
character
do you think i'm the only one
that washed it all the way through no
english dubbing no i think there were
plenty of people who plenty of people
who did even after people
told me to turn the subtitles on i was
like [ __ ] i'm in too deep at this point
i'm not gonna start reading well i
wonder the girl who got her
uh spoiler alert the girl who got her
head absolutely shot in
uh you know the young chick who killed
her dad yeah i wonder what her voice
acting was like what was it
it was all pretty horrendous hey
thanks for being a good friend yeah the
the worst one was the crazy chick
because it's like really hard to sound
crazy without acting crazy at the same
time yeah
like i wish we had an example of that
but it was so bad let this play out
what's the remaining 10 seconds
what kind of nonsense is this
what makes no sense at all oh god
you can't possibly mean that
what kind of nonsense what kind of
crappy nonsense is it
like damn yeah good show though yeah uh
i mean for a shitty show yeah for a
horrible show yeah yeah that dialogue
was
uh
atrocious yeah
um tournaments also
who the [ __ ] was that whoa oh dale
that's dale yeah what a crazy
[ __ ] yeah he likes to go for a
little joy floats yeah you'll probably
see him a couple more times he's just
like he's weird like that joey orbitz
djorbit orbits
orbiting again